Sneaky snake
Hey there! You're gonna need to get past
that snake...You'll be fine...If you don't wake it up.
What happens if I wake it up?
Urp *screams*
OH GOD! The snake...
*laughs quietly* Oh shit...OH GOD NO!
*demonic inhale* It's enough snake
That snake is sneaky
Whoops! That's *groan of disgust*
HEY SNAKE!
HEY BUDDY!
How ya doing?
DON'T KILL ME!!
*Screams in realization that the snake could care less about Markimoo's life*
Uhh...let me live...let me just live
Ohhh hey
Please
Please let me live
Please let me―BLAH! *thinks he forgot to let Chika out*
oh...I didn't want to see the death (ᘳ⊜﹏⊜ᘰ)
*Gladiator scream* Awh shit
*Demon Markimoo starts to come out*
This is horrifying...this is horrifying
*screams* uh...
Gotta trick the snake...AH HA!!
See! HA HA! HA HA HA! HA!
Sneaky snake not so sneaky anymore
Now me I'm-uhhh get away from me...get away from me
GET AWAY FROM ME! DON'T-NO!
OH! IT TOOK MY HELMET
*Celebratory woahs*
Hey snake
Haw. Wooo hooo!
Ahhaha! Hey tall boy
Well...I win in my mind
Fack~ you
Hehehehe. Joke's on you, I didn't like my legs
Hep...fuck. Oh! Wo-wo-wo
Hefer
How are you-AWHH! Not like that
Sassy BOI! Wohohohohoho
HEY! HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
I'll take it! You know what, victory's a victory.
*Drunk Santa voice* DWOO. WHAT? OH.
OKAY. KIDDIES! I DON'T THINK
OH GOD! GET IN THE HOLE [( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)] WHOA~
OKAY KIDDIES, WE DON'T NEED FLYING POWERS HERE.
*Drunk Santa groan* KIDDIES JUST-KIDDIES JUST
KIDDIES! JUST GET IN THE FUCKING HOLE
GOD DAMN IT KIDDIES
YOU SONS OF BITCHES BETTER NOT RUIN THIS FOR SANTA
JUST GET IN THE GOD DAMN HOLE
GET IN THE FUCKING HOLE! OH FUCK YOU!! OH FUCK YOU!
KIDDIES, JUST GET IN THE GOD DAMN HOLE! FUUUUUUCKKKKK!!!
*Santa gibberish* NOOOOOOOO!!!
FUCK YOU. HOW DOES THIS HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH BIOSHOCK?
THIS DOSEN'T MAKE A GOD DAMN BIT OF SENSE.
*Various drunk Santa groans* AHHHHH!  NOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
FUCK YOU!!!
*Regular Markimoo voice* Pogoman & gun
I don't know what that means but it can't be good
AHHH! THANK YOU! Thank you for the pro win!
I'd like to thank my mom who has always supported me. Hi mom!
*Deep voice* Stair survival
I don't know about that
Wheeeeeheheheheoh
Isn't this the most fun you've ever had?
Dohhh~ Fuck
Alright, let's try this the way that it wants
without the flying cheaters
Boink! Hehe! Can't beat me! Boink!
Okay, so far so goo. Ow! Well, lost son, can't be bothered about that at the moment
In a bit of a predicament
HEY! Sorry!! Okay!
Can you win?
What the?
Oh! Ow, my butt
He eh~ Whoahohohohohohohahoho! That was creative! *adorable giggle*
Escape the ship. Hi Sergeant! You are trying to escape a military ship but there
are reds (bad guys) everywhere. Escape the ship alive. (If you want a bit of a challenge,
try keeping your son alive)
Well, I don't know if I'm mon do that *groans*
I saved myself for you son (?)
Uhhhh BOSKI! Ha boski! Excuse me. Alright
Don't know why there is a battleaxe there...
I'm killing up a storm over here. Get your corpse out of the way of my victory!
Well shit.
Alright, this time is gonna be different *battle cry*
AH! My balls! Hyup...OW!
Why?!
Gravity was really high in that one area
Hup! Fuck you! Hahahaha...hahahah...hahahaha
AHHAHAHAH! AH *Wild Markimoo mating call*
🎶Any minute now, victory is gonna be mine!🎶
🎶Fuck you, fuck you, fuck all of you!🎶
🎶Fuck you too, fuck me in the face🎶
Hwup, BOING! Hahahaha! That's the one, right up your butt old man.
Welp, excuse me, main deck. I seem to be making it. AH! DON'T DO IT LADY! AHH! DON'T DO IT M-SIR
O-Bye son. Thanks for your sacrifice. *Accidentally kills son* O-oh-oh-oh, sorry about that son.
Didn't mean to do that son
I apologize son.
*Drunk Santa Voice* UGH! GET IN THE BOX
WELP, SANTA'S GONNA AN EPIC SWAN-UH OH
THIS IS WHERE SANTA MASSIVE GIRTH DOESN'T DO HIM JU-*Wild Santamoo warning call*
HURP! BACK FLIP.
WELP, THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE BACKWARDS BUT SANTA CAN'T BE PICKY
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT SANTA DO
HURP...URP..*Wild Santamoo mating call*
BACK FLIP THIS TIME, THAT'S WHAT SANTA WAS LOOKING FOR
THIS WAS NECESSARY *Wild Santamoo warning call*
BACK-FLOOHH! IT WAS A TRICK DRAW ON THAT ONE! SANTA, YOU THOUGHT SANTA WAS
WAS BACK FLIPPING, MAYBE I AM, MAYBE I'M NOT. MAYBE I'M A SASSY SANTA TODAY
HUP, WELL. SHIT.
TUCK IT IN. SPREAD THE ARMS. DISLOCATE THE ELBOW
URP, SHIT. ALMOST. HURP, *SCREAMS* I GOT MY ARMS IN! THAT COUNTS!
HUR DAB! *SCREAMS SOME MORE* UWA, URA, URRH, DAP *Wild Santamoo mating call*
*Regular Markimoo Voice* Slow? Fuck slow. Who goes slow? No one.
Losers, that's who. Like my son, who fell behind and went slow. SHIT, AH!
Airb-woah-air-airball?! OH MY GOD! IT'S A SPORT! AH!
I PUT IT IN MY GOAL! I'M SUCH AN ASSHOLE.
GIVE ME THE BALL! GIVE ME THE BALL! AHH, GET AWAY FROM ME, TEAMMATE!
I'LL BODYSLAM YA RIGHT INTO THE GROUND! DON'T MAKE ME PULL AN EPIC SUPLEX.
We got this, any minute now. Nah never mind, we're just gonna have an orgy in our goal net.
Hey, I've always wanted to tell you how much I love you.
Come here! Come here! Come here! COME HERE! AWHH YEAH! AWHH YEAH!!
I'm gonna consider that as actions that I did and not random fate.
Rope fall. Well, I-do I have any control in the matter here or am I just a victim of gravity and happenstance?
Ball fall, air fall. SHIT. AHHH, MY BUTT!
Uhhh, am I still alive? Barely...whoop, nope, not anymore.
DWUH! I'M ABOUT TO, FUCK.
AHHHH! I'M ABOUT TO TAKE YOU-urp
TO THE THUNDERDOME WITH-fuck.
WH-I'M GONNA GET YOU NOW THAT-FUCK.
BWAHHHHH, GET READY!
AHHH-I'M GONNA-ahhh, fuck this.
GONNA GET YA THAT-FUCK!
*🐸* BWUAH! Ah fuck.
FUUUU-GAHHHH-GU-GUN GET YOU IN THE THUNDERDOME BABY! *pause* YAAAAAAHHHHHH~
This has been Happy Wheels Highlights, thanks for watching!
If you wanna see more happy wheels right now, check the description or click the annotation
for the full Happy Wheels playlist! And if you wanna see more Happy Wheels in the future, please click the like button to let me know
Thanks again everyone, and as always, I'll see you in the next video! Bye bye!